thousands of miles from the
Mediterranean Pakistani families are
waiting for answers are amongst the
hundreds of migrants missing after an
overcrowded boat capsized off the coast
of Greece
we came to know about the incident
through media Muhammad's nephew o Vice
is still missing the lack of information
for him for all of these families is
devastating
I want to know about our children we
want to know if they are alive or dead
it's in God's hands
the fishing boat crammed with migrants
and Asylum Seekers capsized off the
Southwest coast of Greece on Wednesday
morning leaving at least 78 people known
dead but many more missing
it's estimated that 300 of those could
be from Pakistan at least 10 of them
come from this small village bandali in
the Azad Kashmir region of Pakistan
a few days back one of my nephews taught
with his son here and asked him when I
reached Italy what gift should I send to
you when we remember this it's very
depressing for us God help us
more than 30 men have been arrested in
the nearby town of cotley accused of
helping the people Smugglers
but here they don't seem to blame them
we can't blame agents who send them it's
our fault agents told them it's a
life-threatening journey to Italy they
told you that you don't even get food
during the journey for days
so far the Greek authorities have
rescued 104 survivors and they say
they'll keep searching but as Pakistan
prepares to enter a day of mourning the
authorities don't expect to find anyone
else alive
Alistair bunkel Sky News